for those you just joining know i don't
have sound effects but
i do them with my mouth when i'm
scrolling
number nine josh hoyt number eight is
scotus but we've been we've been doing
that for long enough so let's go to
number nine josh holly
josh holly this [ __ ]
yep
oh i gotta and hang on i gotta go copy
because you know when we read tweets
we actually uh give credit
we give credit we give credit here on
the [ __ ] list roundup to the tweets we
read
we want to make sure they know that they
were on uh
that they were on the [ __ ] list this is
the clip i'm looking for ron has this
clip of mr josh holly talking at the
fragile men's conference oh excuse me i
think it's the uh national conservatism
conference
i thought it was the fragile mail the
white male incel conference that he was
speaking at the convention of the incels
um but um he's speaking on stage here
and uh ron says josh hawley says more
men today are watching porn and playing
video games because their masculinity
has been criticized
all those poor little [ __ ] snowflakes
oh
they're poor little snowflakes let's go
ahead and make this screen bigger
because i definitely want you to see
this
this [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] so um let's
let's let's retweet ron here and i i've
been waiting all morning to show you
guys this i'm really excited about this
um
i'm really excited about this video this
video of josh ollie and there's several
reasons why i'm excited because a lot of
people are alluding to that
that this that this video of josh
ollie's he's projecting here maybe he's
a little insensitive oh they're
criticizing my my white maleness my
masculinity as if josh holly is the
[ __ ] picture of masculinity what the
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
josh holly is no [ __ ]
picture of masculinity i mean when i
think masculine and manliness josh
hawley is the one of the last [ __ ]
images that comes to my mind
this [ __ ] rube well let's let's
listen to what this
[ __ ] says here and then we'll i'll
i'll i'll rip him on the other side
we'd be surprised
that after years of being told that they
are the problem that their manhood is
the problem
more and more men are withdrawing into
the enclave of idleness and pornography
and video games
oh i found the comment by one young man
oh one young man wall street journal
reporter particularly it must have been
that one young man must have been in a
uh
in a chat thread he was in on call of
duty or something well while joshie was
down in his sister's basement because
you know he doesn't have a he doesn't
have a house in missouri he doesn't live
in missouri lives in virginia so when he
comes to missouri he has to stay in his
sister's basement so i'm sure he's
playing video games in his sister's
basement call of duty and
someone mentioned in the chat thread oh
i'm so oppressed
i'm a white male in this country and so
oppressed
i mean doesn't it really seem like uh
these in-cell white males are just
desperate i mean they're [ __ ]
desperate
desperate to be oppressed what the [ __ ]
are you
ninka poops yammering on about you're
oppressed
you get to watch porn and play video
games all day what are you talking about
most people have to work three or four
goddamn jobs that have paid minimum wage
just to pay their [ __ ] rent let alone
have the the [ __ ] internet so they
can watch porn and play video games get
the [ __ ] out of here
evocative
and particularly heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking
waiting for a light to come on oh a
light so i can figure out i guess i
guess i guess he can't afford the light
bulb either that or his hands are too
sticky to go up and turn it on i don't
know what to do oh what to do next can
we be surprised
that after years of being so a lot of
people are saying that josh alley is
projecting here and that may be the
[ __ ] case that he's projecting that
he's sitting sitting in his sister's
basement watching porn and playing call
of duty all [ __ ] day and all [ __ ]
night but my guess is
and i'll let me go to my profile because
i want to show you what i tweeted about
it because this is what i believe to be
true is that josh hawley thinks he's
going to rall him up an army of these
white male incels
[Music]
imagine trying to gather up an army of
fragile white male victims of porn and
video game addiction
that's the thing
that's the thing is that they're trying
to make this as if um
you know
again these white males are desperate
desperate to be the oppressed so that
they you know because they they they
they love to watch
they love they love
they love to watch themselves
be little [ __ ] as mayo says here
josh hawley is a little [ __ ] because
that is the truth
that is the truth josh holly is a little
[ __ ]
let's see what's what's brooklyn dad
defiance say here
josh hawley's
insistence that porn can you guys see
that there we go insistence that porn
and video games are linked to men's
masculinity being criticized sounds like
his alibi for when his wife busted him
playing a porn video
see everyone's alluding to the fact that
it's possible it's possible that josh
hawley uh maybe got caught uh playing
video games and watching porn maybe all
at the same time i don't know
i don't play video games
so i mean when when i say i don't play
video games i don't like i don't like go
on and you know i call a dude or
anything like that i don't i don't i
don't play video games
not that it's wrong or it's bad i just i
just don't play video games and i no
comment on the porn no
comment
but a lot of people are alluding to the
fact that maybe josh holly is addicted
to porn and video games and he's really
really really trying to sell his wife on
the reason why is because it's because
he's he's oppressed he's oppressed i
mean we've made these these white males
in this country feels so insignificant
that all i can do is jag off and play
video games all day get the [ __ ] out of
here
you know we like avenger resistor here
so people of virginia or missouri elect
josh holly to study male masculinity i
have questions yeah exactly
because he's not exactly the the picture
of masculinity at all this [ __ ] rube
oh here we go jason kander's probably
got a good one jason kander
jason kander says if josh holly is an
expert on masculinity then i'd like to
take a few minutes to share my thoughts
on quantum physics
son of a [ __ ]
and
jason kander
gets the alley-oop i i retweeted this
earlier um this is fantastic scary larry
says translation josh hawley sits around
spanking it to porn all day
so he thinks all other men do too
especially white males that look like
him
what would kid hitler know about
masculinity anyways
i can't hitler that's fantastic
oh it's a great nickname
for fist pump josh
oh should we stop digging on josh ollie
no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no
but this is the this is the video of
of josh holly
um
of him talking about masculine oh here
we go
race race mr race bannon says
josh holly thinks masculinity is under
attack look at him look how masculine
look at look how masculine
he is
in the in the wine section
of whole foods
there
so masculine
so
masculine
you [ __ ] break
these people don't know what masculinity
is they have no [ __ ] clue
hassan actually had a good one here
he mentioned hopefully these things do
josh holly is a stanford grad who buys
asparagus water and old foods asparagus
water apparently
i don't know what asparagus water is but
apparently it's i think in whole foods
and it's a thing that masculine men
drink apparently it's like a masculine
it's like a masculine men
type
thing
machine pun kelly says i masturbate to
own the libs
[Laughter]
these jokes just do not get old
they just do not get old
[Music]
i masturbate to own the libs
fantastic thank you machine pun kelly
do we want to keep reading these these
josh holly jokes i think so
for [ __ ] sake says who thinks josh
hawley is a participant in the
insurrection [ __ ]
yes yes of course he is look at the
picture down there he was yeah whoo
you're about to about to come and take
over cheeto dust kangaroo
i mean he was he was the object of him
was to get the senate
they had to have a few senators to uh
object
to the certification of the 2020
presidential results the state
certifications
so um when they did that so let's go
let's go uh so do we are we done with
josh holly i i think i'm knowing